take a look at homer bailey his career
versus the tigers has been very good
bailey activated from the 45-day injured
list the future hall of famer miguel
cabrera 37 years old and the 0-1 a
ground ball to short from shallow left
field audrey onto fields and throws out
cabrera and that's out number three
welcome back bailey a nine pitch one two
three
first inning and now the twins get ready
to face the 23 year old from kingman
arizona tarik skubal scoops is making
his
seventh start of the season already his
third start against the twins it's
buxton donaldson and then rosario twins
lineup tonight no cruz no polanco on the
wind up and the 1-1 a swinging drive to
left field deep down the line back it
goes deep it goes and that ball is going
to be fair and gone
lead off homer down the left field line
for byron buxton who is red hot here in
september
his 13th overall home run
and the twins one batter in take a
one-nothing lead
and that is byron's second career
lead-off home run his first was it
inside the parker off chris sale back in
2016 and now leading off against
squibble takes him deep down the left
field line and the twins club their 86th
home run and lead one zip they are
sporting a little playoff swag tonight
courtesy of josh donaldson there are
some playoff robes that josh bought for
the entire team and support staff this
kid is if you could keep him healthy he
is an elite
outfielder
strikes out buxton nice job buxton got
the better of him the first time
scuba turns the tables here in the third
josh donaldson
payoff and he struck him out tarik
skubal's got some overpowering stuff
tonight that's punch out number five
meanwhile willie castro singles up the
middle yeah we got a little action going
on here and runners at the corners for
miguel cabrera
cabrera goes to right center and that'll
find the alley
one run is home
willie castro motoring around second all
the way to third and miguel cabrera
comes through to tie it at one and
bailly showing some signs of struggles
here in the fourth inning nobody out do
some damage control with the tigers
already tying the game up
and he lost him to a walk and they're
loaded up now with nobody else cabrera
will go to second and here comes rocco
baldelli that might be the end of the
night for homer bailey well you got your
jam but it's going to be cody stachek
who's got to deal with it but nobody out
one in base is loaded battle's going to
be brandon dixon
backhanded from his knees force play
there force play at third
a beautiful double play and a great
decision
by mitch garver they got the two lead
runners they said he's gonna have to
work some magic to get out of this he's
not quite out of it yet and here is good
room to bat to center and deep buxton
back
under it now great job by cody stacheck
he got the worst situation you could
possibly have to enter the ball game but
he got out of it and here is mitch
garber
the high fly deep down the left field
line garber got it all
and the twins retain the lead 2-1
that's a real good sign right there for
this minnesota twins ball club you know
garber struggle first part of the season
went on the il
worked on some swing mechanics got
himself healthy
he said his first step out he was
looking a lot more comfortable that bad
got that ball didn't miss it 417 feet
that rome was ready
the homeroom there it is and that hit
adrianza and that will load them up for
byron buxton trying to walk it off
hopefully able to stay in this game and
he will stay in the game says narrow
will pitch to buxton buxton waiting on
an o2 fastball got him on the outside
corner perfect pitch painted at 97.
nero does it again strands three
reya's line driving to left field this
can be a close play rosario's going to
come up throwing and the throw to garber
and he's going to be out at home played
so rosario
puts the pistol away
as cameron
slow getting up at home plate but he was
out by good
three feet good tag by garber second
time that a relief pitcher has had to
come into a tough spot no margin for
error with the bases loaded there are
two outs this time and now romine will
hit against duffy and his slider her
ball grounded right back off of duffy
he'll go to the right of the mound throw
to first a little bit low and out of the
glove of snow
wow
drives one to left field and rosario
makes the catch
to end the ending one across for the
tigers first man up dazz cameron
seeing the line drive to right field
heading toward the gap and it's going to
split the outfielders one hop to the
wall has cameron around first and he
will cruise into second with his second
double of the night wins draw the
infield in tight willy castro at the
plate
swinging a line drive base hit into
right field
into score comes cameron willie castro
delivers again tigers lead it 3-2 here
in the seventh kepler one for three
tonight is single as he rips one high
and deep to right field back it goes
deep it goes and gone
kepler ties it up and this game is even
3-3 nelson crows has that home run rove
ready carvers put it on and now kepler
does the same on career home run number
101 runners at the corners with only one
away for jamer candelario
sharply hit through the drawn in infield
to left
tigers have the lead
do up here in the bottom of the 10th
rosario cenote and garver
that's poked a center field down for a
hit and it'll tie the game kay flies
around third and we're even
at four
winning runs at second with two down
from max kepler
to left field short left field down for
a hit rosario will come around and score
and the twins walk off the tigers then
max kepler as we've seen when he gets
hot look out